When I was a boy, I had to choose paths.
Or fate would choose for me.
I've hurt people
and I'm going to hurt more.
I'm asking forgiveness for what I'm about to do.
So I just.
Gang war.
The city
crumbles.
My, we are the only ones we can trust.
A trail.
That's not something that I can forgive.
Nothing about.
This brings me joy.
You brought this on yourself.
It hurts me.
I have to kill you.
Welcome back, everyone.
Is Charlie Marvel just released a special new daredevil
Marvel Netflix trailer confirming where
all the Marvel Netflix series fit in the MCU timeline
basically confirming that it was all canon to the MCU.
There were a couple of Marvel producers that actually
make all the TV shows that they're making right now.
That also confirmed it, too.
So we'll break it all down.
there's a bunch of new footage
here, a bunch of new daredevil.
So I'll explain
when all the characters are also coming back
because there is a plan for some of them right now.
some of them will take a little bit longer
to come back, but they will all eventually come back.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
Of course,
they'll do videos for whatever they wind up releasing.
know.
Everybody's asking when the agents of Shield
characters are coming back to.
Because a lot of people thought that Daisy
Johnson, myself included,
would come back during Secret Invasion.
There was a bit of a back that they fumbled.
So hopefully marvel will fix that in some point
in the next couple of years.
but this is one of the main Marvel producers
who works on all the Marvel TV shows
that they're making right now, explaining how
all the Marvel Netflix stuff is canon to the main MCU
and what's changed this finally getting them
to actually acknowledge that in a public way,
not just in a sort of a roundabout way
where the actors talk about it, up until this point,
we've been a little bit cagey
about what's sacred timeline.
What's not sacred timeline that was that was born of,
frankly, a period at the studio where we were like,
we have to stick the landing with Avengers.
Sure.
You know, it was it was another part of the company
developing the Netflix stuff.
We were aware of what they were doing.
They were aware of we were doing.
But it was it was a it was it was a lot.
It was a lot to balance anyway.
But now that, you know, to some time has passed,
now that we see how actually how
well integrated the stories are.
would be confident
in saying it is part of the sacred time.
there was a bunch of inside baseball stuff
that he dropped there.
So when he talks about making vendors happy, quote
unquote, he's talking about Netflix specifically like
they are the other vendor that Marvel was working with
when they were producing all the defenders stuff.
basically back in the day,
Marvel ordered all those defenders shows.
Punisher is an exception because he just was introduced
during Daredevil season two
in originally Netflix didn't start out
ordering a Punisher series But Jon Bernthal as Punisher
was so fantastic during Daredevil season two that
they wanted to bring him back on his own solo show.
So they ordered a brand new Punisher
show as part of it.
Like on top of all the other defenders stuff
that they'd already ordered for all the other different
shows and their team up show.
but early on Netflix ordered that whole block of shows
and they had a very specific idea
about how they wanted it
to all work in crossover with each other.
And it was a completely different group inside Marvel
that was producing it,
which is what this Marvel producer is talking about,
like another group, not us.
He's part of the Marvel Studios and the things in.
At that time, Marvel Studios was really only working
on the movies, like That's Kevin Varghese purview,
like all of his stuff.
Now, the TV shows are under his umbrella, but
that didn't happen until just a couple of years ago.
all the Marvel Netflix stuff happened
when Jeph Loeb was in charge of Marvel TV,
and it was this very clear demarcation
like TV stuff was a different group.
Movie stuff was Kevin Feige, his group,
But every time a brand new season of the Marvel
Netflix stuff came out like Daredevil,
even the Defenders series, Luke Cage, all that stuff,
they would always reference stuff from the MCU.
So people would always wonder, like,
when are they actually going to see an MCU character
inside the Netflix series?
even the Russo brothers, when we got to Avengers
Infinity War in Avengers Endgame were like,
It is possible
we could see the Netflix characters in there,
but then eventually they kind of changed their tune.
We're like, Well, there's already so many characters.
It's kind of hard to figure out how to work
all those other Netflix characters in.
Also, on top of all that, generally
just felt like they were giving us the run around,
like Marvel Studios people the movie people was
didn't really want to deal with the TV stuff, but
it sounds like based on what the producer is saying,
that they always wanted to bridge that gap.
there was just something going on
in their contractual level with Netflix
that was preventing them from doing that.
Like it was more of a contractual issue.
All that stuff expired a long time ago.
For all the shows, so it's all a moot point now,
To be honest, that's probably why they waited until now
to actually verbally acknowledge it and put it
in all of these trailers like, yeah, by the way,
it's all canon So if it wasn't clear
in the trailer here, they're including footage
from the actual Netflix series.
So they want to show you that it is canon
by using it in their trailer for new MCU stuff.
Primarily the Echo series.
for those of you wondering
if Daredevil is now canon to the MCU,
that means that everything that happened on
the Daredevil series is now part of their backstories.
When you see them in the MCU, like Spider-Man, No Way
Home, the Hawkeye Series, when Kingpin comes back,
all the stuff that happened to them
after the events of Daredevil Season three,
because that was sort of like the last big series
before they canceled everything that's all meant
to go down before the snap because that's around
when that was happening in the movies.
a lot of people now asking what happened to Daredevil
during the snap, too?
Did he get snapped?
my assumption, just based on the dramatic way
they write the character is that Matt
did not get snapped.
But his friends like Foggy
Nelson, Karen Page did get snapped.
we make all the Daredevil
and Spider-Man team up references like it sounds like
Daredevil is going to be inspired me in four
but one of the big similarities
in the way that they write the characters is all about
what you can take away from them.
And they still continue to want to be a superhero
helping people.
so you have to imagine some of the saddest stuff
happened to Matt during that five year time jump.
Just like the worst period in his life.
one of the reasons why I think they're
including all these kingpin flashbacks
to to his childhood of him killing his father.
And they've included some of this footage
in previous trailers to where it was
in black and white,
making it seem like they're having some new flashbacks.
I think that's just because they want to juxtapose
his upbringing with Maya
Echo's upbringing, because he basically raises her
after her father's death in
it seems like they've actually clarified
that the fight that she has with Daredevil
is meant to be when she's still basically a kid
like basically a teenager.
so it sounds like that's going to be a flashback
and that's
why his daredevil suit
looks like the classic Netflix suit, because it's
when he was still actually wearing that is before
he got his new suits during the trailer when Kingpin
is actually talking about choosing a path though, he's
meant to be talking to Maya, to Echo's character.
part of the idea is that when he was raising her,
he was raising her in this way of violence,
teaching her the way of violence, the way that he's
justifying that is that if he didn't actually
take that action, if he didn't kill his father,
then his life would be completely out of his control.
Like he didn't want to lose that control for him
though it means being super violent super stabby.
love the way in the trailer here
when they're showing you the daredevil.
This is from the end of season one,
how they desaturated the colors,
but they tune them way up on the red of his costume.
the line in the trailer
where he's talking about asking for forgiveness
for what he's about to do is actually
from the very opening scene of Daredevil season one.
we get a quick montage of kingpin and daredevil
across the events of the Daredevil
Netflix series Season one through three
when he's talking about the city
crumbling like all these gang wars, all this craziness.
Part of his idea is that he does want to fix the city.
But is his way of violence like he thinks?
Is it by crushing it I think they also included that
in the trailer to inform what's going to be happening
with this character during the events of Daredevil
Born Again, even though they've changed
some aspects of that series,
the basic overarching plot is meant to be the same.
And he's running for mayor like Mayor Kingpin
like he was in the comics.
is all meant to be part of the whole Marvel Phase
five Dark Reign era, where villains
take positions of power. Any rules?
New York City with an iron fist
Making as many defenders puns as possible.
The funny thing is they canonize Daredevil
all this other defenders stuff.
That means that the events of Iron Fist
are also canon do.
That doesn't mean
that they're not going to recast some people, but
generally the events of Iron Fist
are still meant to be Canon.
that's actually one of the reasons why Jessica Henwick
actually turned down the role of I think, Shang.
She's sister.
She was supposed to play in the young movie.
she said that she was offered that role,
but she had to pick between that
and being in the Matrix movie
and she picked the Matrix movie because she knew that
if she picked the Shang Xi role, then
that means she probably would not come back as Colleen
Wing from Iron Fist.
And she's probably one of the best things
about the Iron Fist series.
little bit of time would have gone by
since the end of season two.
So we'll see.
Really important, though, you have to remember that
the events of all those series
basically ended before Infinity War happened,
before the snap happened.
So it's been more than five years
for most of those people.
all the other Marvel producers
didn't say exactly who's going to cameo in the series
besides Daredevil's character.
just because they're only five
episodes, I'm not expecting a bunch of them.
I think most of the cameos will actually come
during Daredevil Born Again
once we get to those episodes, but they're just
starting work on the brand new version of Daredevil.
Born Again Interestingly enough to make more Netflix
defenders references, they actually have
some of the writers from Punisher actually now
showrunning that along with some of the Loki writers.
So when they say they're doing things
more hardcore in the Netflix style,
they're literally actually doing that now
because that's all can like they're just continuing
with like the next season that just happened to call it
Daredevil Born Again, I've already done
a bunch of videos about Jessica Jones coming back.
Punisher is also a main character during Daredevil
Born Again.
The only person that I think isn't coming right back
are two people that I think are coming right back.
Are Luke Cage
just because he's so booked up on other projects.
More of an availability issue
than anything else in Iron Fist
because Kevin Foggy probably trying to figure out
how he's going to do the Iron Fist character
because now Shang,
she is like the main go to martial artist in the MCU.
I've already explained my theory
about how they should reintroduce Iron fist
like if you're going to recast Iron Fist
use him in Sheng Shi too.
But I don't think they're going to do that.
Even as cool as it sounds.
But if all this TV stuff is meant to be canon now,
when do you want them to bring some of the agents
of SHIELD characters?
Back now to we do have secret wars coming up,
but they're like a lot of other Marvel TV series
that they're producing that they could actually fit
some of these characters in,
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
I'll start doing my echo
episode videos as they start releasing them.
Remember, they're all dropping them at the same time,
so I'll just be a couple videos for it
instead of like the weekly regular episodes like I do
for all the other Marvel series.
Marvel just announced
that they're working on a Midnight Sun series.
Click here to learn about that and all the characters
that would show up during it and click here for that.
What if Season 3 trailer and learn about
some of the new stories they're doing during that
Thank you so much for watching
Happy New Year and I'll see you guys in the next one!